when covid-19 emerged the push to
contain another virus took a back seat
it seems that people kind of almost
forgot about HIV vimbayi munyanara helps
women living with the disease in London
Ontario and her work is personal from a
very young age I've lost family members
friends but I also have a lot of family
friend family members and friends who
are living with HIV today she was born
in Zimbabwe a country with one of the
highest rates of HIV in the world the
first documented case in Canada was 41
years ago
science has come a long way since then
groundbreaking discoveries like
antiretrovirals or Arts keep people
alive and prevent transmission by making
the virus undetectable there is no cure
but researchers at the University of
Ottawa are Paving a way towards one
pinpointing where the virus goes in the
body once it's become latent what we're
trying to do here is not replace the
antiretrovirals but to prevent the virus
from hiding so that we can actually get
rid of the virus we've made remarkable
progress in understanding the disease
but progress costs money the pandemic
drained resources for research and
slowed testing and treatment we're
clearly moving in the wrong direction We
Were Somehow being complacent in
thinking that this is no longer a crisis
and therefore we can just go on business
as usual last year the federal
government spent 50 million dollars on
HIV and hepatitis C prevention support
and testing but Aid organizations insist
they need twice that with infections
increasing around 5 percent annually
it's shooting up like from where it was
and I can only imagine it or I can only
believe it's due to the lack of funding
and until more action is taken Canadians
living with HIV will suffer
unnecessarily because Advocates believe
it's not science that's standing in the
way of progress but a lack of political
wealth
Global News Ottawa